[Music]
hello you're watching GameSpot daily
where we cover six gaming news stories
in 30 minutes or less I'm Callie and I'm
joined by Michael hi I'm what up it's a
day two of gamespot daily this is our
second show this is GameSpot's new news
show new news hard to say yeah we try
and keep a chill here we're not gonna
yell at you or you know try and be very
loud like some people we might know but
uh you know take it easy yeah we're like
to chill out yeah so welcome we are
talking about several cool things today
yes the headlines suggest GTA it's one
of those things we're also talking about
Dark Souls and The Simpsons
drama yeah we're gonna get into it we're
gonna get into some some pretty deep
[ __ ] here but uh maybe I don't know how
deep it's gonna go yeah but we're gonna
go what do you wanna you want to start
lighting we're gonna start we're gonna
start light and easy I think yeah all
right story number one Dark Souls
remastered fixes Blighttown this comes
from polygon look tell me about this cuz
I'm not a big I'm not very familiar with
dark the dark souls who what do I start
well Dark Souls is a game cool it's a
good game but so far so good so the
thing about a light Blighttown is an
area is a city and in Dark Souls and the
problem was that framerate drops were
very dramatic in the original game on
ps3 and xbox 360 you were getting
probably drops to like 10 frames per
second which is a very big impact in a
game where split-second reactions could
mean life or death because in Dark Souls
you should know how hard it is and when
you miss out on those frames it makes it
really hard to dodge makes it hard to
attack when the time is right or get
readings on an enemy attack patterns so
the story here is that what is this a
switch version this is dorsals
remastered we're watching yeah off
screen game okay so just yeah okay so
this is Dark Souls remastered and they
it seems that they have fixed the
framerate issues in play town awesome
which is great which is what you would
expect from a remaster version hopefully
yeah you would hope so and this gameplay
comes from somebody at PAX who just went
straight to blight town just to check it
out yeah
infamous I would say yeah a lot of
people know about the issues with play
town mm-hmm but you should know that the
remastered version will be running
smooth even on switch which is awesome
to hear especially because the switch
frame rate is lower than the ps4 and
Xbox one frame it's only 30 fps right
yeah so it seems that I mean we already
knew this going in that the switch
version will be 720p 30fps I think when
yeah yeah that's how it's gonna be so
it's gonna be a lot a lot and I would
say luck but it's a capped 30 as to
whether it's steady throughout the
entire game it remains to be seen but
the ps4 and Xbox one versions will be
running 60fps and the pro version the
pro and Xbox one next versions I believe
are getting 4k mmm and 60fps oh my god
check my facts boy believe that's
correct yes what if it's not you can
correct us but be nice yeah be nice come
on we also have our own just general
off-screen gameplay of Dark Souls
remastered if you want to check that out
just like more of the game and not just
bite down but yeah Dark Souls remastered
come to switch this is gonna be pretty
dope I've decided about the amiibo cuz
I'm excited about the yeah I really want
that amiibo yeah
the solar just like that praise the Sun
y'all that's how you do it too bad we
were like in a tiny window when we know
that that's fine yeah I I'm looking
forward to like playing this game for
the first time because for the first
time I've been very there was something
in the frame that made me laugh don't
worry about it ok I've just been so
intimidated by this game so you you have
have you played any souls board games
barely barely barely oh you missing out
I know so yeah that starts old Dark
Souls Dark Souls remastered and that's
only one of six stories we're talking
about yes we're gonna we're gonna get to
some some big ones yeah don't worry
don't worry GTA is coming like Korean
companies getting fined for loop box a
little loot box controversies yeah
switch a bruiser
if you thought summer such such if you
thought loot boxes we're gonna go out of
the news you were wrong uh
comes from kotaku three companies were
fined by the Korean fair trade
commission for deceptive loot box
practices and it totals over nine
hundred fifty thousand dollars
so next floor was fined only forty six
hundred net marble was fifty five grand
and the Nexen was the bulk of it
$875,000 next I'm taking a taking a hit
they're gonna big hit yeah so our good
friend michael transactions has made it
into our show it's michael transactions
debut yeah that's what we we called
those i'm right here micro transactions
micro transactions come up frequently so
this is the the last you've heard of it
i'm sure this is not the last one this
is extremely oh my god this this if
you're watching if you're watching right
now this is super did we yeah yeah it's
supposed to be this fast okay that was
crazy so anyway this is sudden attack
which is NEX ons online shooter and
that's the reason we bring it up is
because that was one of the particular
reasons that next one was find so
drastically so they had an event yet
collect sixteen puzzle pieces for a
special reward and two pieces were only
found in 85 cent loot boxes but you had
an equal chance of finding one of the
two pieces but they only appear in point
zero five percent not point five percent
or five percent point zero five percent
of loot boxes had those puzzle pieces in
it and one player spent four hundred
thirty dollars trying to get those
puzzle pieces which amounts to around
five hundred loot boxes purchased which
is insane damn you y'all getting snaked
out there yeah
watch out got yes yeah and then this is
a quote from the korean herald they have
said that the FC ft c-- Fair Trade
Commission's actions have signaled alarm
across the Korean game sector as it
could hurt the sales of in-game items
particularly randomized items which
users tend to continuously buy until
they get their desired result that
contribute immensely to profits whoo boy
so they're cracking down on Michael
transactions that guy is everywhere that
guy it was straight to jail
yeah well he's getting fine
next on isn't Korea's getting fined yeah
next on isn't any publisher as you
should know they this particular case is
for their game sudden attack but there
are also the publisher of lawbreakers
which we talked about yesterday
and they also publish maplestory
maplestory
if y'all know what's up with maplestory
your real one I used to go home and I
have not heard maplestory in forever but
I think personally I also was a
maplestory
in okay I used to come home it was 10th
grade I would walk home after ROTC
practice and I would eat I wouldn't
drink energy 10th grade that's great
yeah ok I was a sophomore in high school
and I would rush home after ROTC
practice and play maplestory with my
home oh man they people start was cute
as hell that sounds awesome
I missed me some maplestory but next on
next on isn't isn't shame on you isn't
some trouble right what baby I they be
ight okay I didn't
whatever I was just excited because we
finally got to the GTA stories know
everybody's here that's sweet headline
we posted everywhere so now we're going
to go into we've to yeah back to back
we got a GTI segment for y'all it uh
kind of in different directions but it
all has to do with the money yeah well
start with the bad news yeah former rock
star note north president Leslie Benzies
150 million dollar lawsuit against take
two has hit a setback like I said it's
only bad news depending on how you look
at it for the best this is like for the
best but basically Benzies filed a
lawsuit in 2016 claiming that rock stars
parrot company take two owes him a
hundred fifty million dollars in
royalties and he also alleged that he
was forced out of the company
and so what happened was the New York
Supreme Court ruled recently that the
profit sharing agreement that he signed
doesn't entitle him to all of the
damages that he's seeking and yeah so
that's sorry Benzies yep this thing is
complicated let's pull up some beer
watching fun GTA while we talk about the
serious court stuff we got a lot of
bullet notes because this
obviously goes in many different
directions but uh sewer here we're here
okay according to the ruling take two
successfully claimed that Benzies
breached the royalty agreement he signed
with company in 2009 and is not be and
is not to be entitled to the money our
note say is not be entitled not be
entitled but in 2012 Benzies became a
rockstar principle for his contributions
to the company's games over the years
and the Supreme Court noted that the
language in the 2009 royalty plan quote
contains no language mandating equal
payments to the principal's so despite
being a principal the agreement he
signed doesn't entitle him to all the
money and of course the reason this is a
big deal because gta5 makes a [ __ ] ton
of money money which we'll get to in a
minute but more details on the bends in
his court case so the court also ruled
that in the terms of agreement are
unambiguous and are not over and by the
2012 agreement Benzies signed
however take-two has failed to show that
legally their interpretation of the 2012
employment agreement is the only
reasonable one that's a quote
so the Supreme Court will not dismiss
Benzies claims for royalties specific to
that 2012 okay yeah and on top of that
the court preliminary early preliminary
that's a cool word I've never used cited
with Benzies when it came to his
improper termination from rock stars
let's break that down cuz that part is I
think I kind of know this story off the
top of my head okay
oh yeah fact fact check me so I think a
long story short is that I think around
2014 or 2015 somewhere on the time
Leslee the fact that I have so therefore
I cannot check in Leslie Benzies are the
bends yeah this is after GTA 5 released
on ps3 and xbox 360 so she was in 2013
post 2013 there abouts anyway he went on
a 17 month sabbatical just like dipped
out on vacation 17 months by the way
that's like what nothing I barely get
like a day off I don't even got 17 ow
ever yeah but uh so then he came back
after a 17 month sabbatical which he
alleges he was encouraged to do which is
an important note so here I just like oh
they were like Oh bends the bends may we
call you the bends
please take 17 months off yeah he went
okay like hell yeah and then he came
back and they didn't have a job for him
anymore
yeah he was like oh yeah you work here
I'm sorry we're here with the BMW now
okay and so he he alleges in the lawsuit
that that was basically them forcing him
out of the company yeah and and like we
said the court preliminarily sided with
him on that claim and I think if I
recall correctly based on a rock star
lore is that the Benz is I mean he's no
he's no slouch I think that like when
Red Dead Redemption was kind of on the
brink of release there's still a lot of
things that needed to be finished so
they called in the bends and then he
came in there and like set that ship
sailing in the right direction to get
Red Dead Redemption out in proper form
for its release date so that's that's
kind of the story behind the bends and
what he can do for Rockstar yeah but
yeah this his case the story of the day
is that can't go ain't winning he's not
entitled to that money as far as the
court is concerned I mean this is the
initial lawsuit so 150 million do you
can go on like yeah hella sabbatical an
indefinite sabbatical yeah that would
hey hook me up with a hundred fifty
million dollars I'll do I do something
special with that yeah help the world
with more GTA news an analyst says it
isn't likely that Rockstar will have
another hit on the scale of GTA 5 and
this is probably one of my favorite
quotes that I've ever read so just get
ready for this so co-ed and company out
analyst Doug Kreutz
I think is how you provide smooth fruits
doesn't think red dead redemption
redemption too will sell as well as
Grand Theft Auto 5 which we said is
makes a [ __ ] ton of money was my exact
wording but Kreutz said to market watch
and this is so good yeah this quote is
something that's not to say Rockstar
won't have other big hits it may but
another GTA v isn't likely Michael
Jackson had a lot of hit albums but he
only had one Thriller that's that's a
pretty good way to put it I guess I love
that GTA 5 is the thriller thriller of
rock stars rock stars
yeah thriller had quite a bit of ADD and
a great online component oh yeah and a
lot of micro sands actions can't that's
sustain itself or something yeah so
Kreutz the analyst believes that GTA 5
is a quote wild outlier in the video
game market when it comes to sales which
yeah that game is poppin I'm not wrong
yeah and he was commenting on a piece
that claims that GTA 5 has brought in
six billion dollars in revenue and that
would have and if that is true which
that was a report from I think yesterday
if that's true that would make it the
most successful entertainment product of
any kind any medium in all of history
but there's no hard data to pack back it
up so we'll just roll with that but I do
like they like well you know GTA 5 is
the most successful thing ever
yeah yeah GTA online it's kinda took a
life of its own yeah for sure
and you know that that thing is still
going I played a lot of that with my
with my friends those high sword oh
there's a lot of I don't know I don't
really spend money on I don't really buy
into micro chance actions but your name
is Michael I'll fight that for but yeah
this there's a lot there's a lot of
infrastructure in place for GTA 5 online
- like just continually succeed you
constantly see it on the top of played
steam charts and it's like yeah still
like even last year when we always do
those NPD reports of like the most like
top-selling games like GTA 5 is still
pushing units
still is like hits number one on like a
weekly UK
sales charts and like it's just it's
crushing it as of February like this
past February more than 90 million
copies had been shipped right so that's
and you know yesterday we talked about
how Resident Evil 7 had over 5 million
copies yeah and that was like huge
Capcom was like yeah this is 90 million
ok but we got 9 million though and so
basically they they're baby out the
allegation but the what the analysts
that is yet read dead 2 mmm not gonna
touch that and that but but I don't
think that's like a profound statement
or anything like that's no surprise you
know it's like like Red Dead Redemption
2 is gonna be a huge game probably one
of the most anticipated games in a very
long time but I'm very excited for it
I'm excited for like the the current gen
horses just kidding that's not what I
mean yes but no I'm probably gonna bring
this up in future episodes but my former
boss from my previous job her husband
was a programmer with rockstar one of
the lead programs in rockstar and he did
the horse hair animations and the horse
animations and Red Dead Redemption
that's badass I know I told I was like
eh I'm dipping out for GameSpot peace
out she's like for reals and I was like
play Red Dead Redemption like hey oh
yeah she's like well let me tell you a
story I'm sick that was that loved it so
there you have it
that was our our super long GTA segment
hope everybody is happy with that well
we got two more stories to stick around
mm-hmm and these are some well there's a
doozy and then there's a little bit of a
happier one mm-hmm so I'll start with a
doozy The Simpsons response to racial
stereotyping of up who probably saw this
on Twitter yesterday Sunday night's
episode of The Simpsons addressed recent
criticisms of the character up who who
is the owner of the kwik-e-mart and they
didn't do it very well a lot of fans are
really disappointed so the background
here is that in 2017 comedian Hari
Kondabolu
I'm totally butchering that I'm sorry
released a documentary called the
problem with a poo and it was just
looking at the negative racial
stereotypes associated with that
character you know he's like his classic
long is like thank
you come again like it's super
over-the-top accented and also Hank
Azaria does the voice and he's and he
yeah he's white worth noting and worth
noting Hank Azaria won an Emmy for that
performance in 1988 and so that ties
into the Simpsons response at the time
the documentary came out Azaria
responded on Twitter or actually I don't
know if it was on Twitter but he
responded saying that the situation was
upsetting and that the movie made some
really good points about the character
so Sunday's episode is called no good
Reid goes unpunished and it shows margin
Lisa trying to make a book called the
princess in the garden in offensive to
people in 2018 and they're like editing
it right yeah and we actually have
somebody posted a clip oh yeah yeah and
we have it but I'll just like pull it up
and we'll talk about it but um oh you
didn't pull up the camera oh snap my bad
I'm just like okay it's all good
but yeah so Lisa turns to the camera and
totally like breaks the fourth wall and
you see the picture of up on the
nightstand so basically she says
something that started decades ago and
was applauded and inoffensive is now
politically incorrect what can you do
and then it pans to that picture of up
ooh and the it says don't have a cow on
it and she says like what can you do and
not isn't like what can what what can we
do but it sounds like oh well yeah oh
well what can you do that's such a
that's like that's a damn cop-out right
what can we do it was 20 30 years ago
and it it's like broke still racist 20
years ago but you can say you can you
can fix us and then Marge says like some
things will be dealt with at a later
date and Lisa says if at all which is so
I know a lot of people are probably like
what's the big deal about this and I
think like as somebody who grew up
watching The Simpsons and I was a really
big fan of The Simpsons for a really
long time Lisa was always a really
important character character to me as a
kid and I looked up to her a lot and I
related to her a lot and I think it's
super not cool that they have Lisa
deliver this line yeah this is very out
of character
that's Lisa has always been the voice of
reason in the Simpsons and like when the
Simpsons was like constantly satirizing
you know not just pop culture but like
the current state like current events in
the state of especially American society
I mean like she has like the vegetarian
episode and the episode were she like
she meets that like activist and they
like go tree-hugging in like she's
always the one who stands up for what's
right and she is a foil to her family
and so to have her deliver the line
about like now this is politically
incorrect what can you do
super out of character she's always been
like a progressive kind of embodiment in
the Simpsons yeah now I know that
there's a lot of talk of like like Oh
Simpsons is all about satirizing like
all types of different people and all
types of stereotypes well a racial
stereotype is very different than like
you know Wiggum who's like like like the
got the dumb cop yeah I'm like I'm like
Homer who's like the the lazy naive dad
or whatever like yeah those are
stereotypes but like it's different when
it's a racial stereotype and well you
call the knives out there who want to be
talking about like oh you shouldn't be
offended by this well getting these damn
shoes all right like yeah y'all like if
that's how you feel like I can I
understand how you may have gotten to
that point but take a step back and kind
of think like okay well all right well I
ain't brown so like oh like maybe I
should think about this like well yeah
you probably should yeah it's like not
really anybody else's place to say
whether or not the character about who
is yeah okay like if there if there was
like a like a if it was a predominantly
like cartoon like doesn't show but about
like a Mid West area and they had like a
like a Filipino character who like yeah
well me like obviously my mom has an
accent like immigrants will have the
Filipino a Filipino accent but like if
they're like constantly like their
character shtick was always like this is
there's a Filipino stereotype in like
we're always haggling to get something
for cheaper
like that is very much a thing where
like my mom and my grandma and my
auntie's do and then like if that's the
carryout the stereotype they're trying
to hit with that care during that show
it's like miss me with that [ __ ] yeah so
take a step back think for a minute
before you speak
yeah about things like that if you may
have not understand but try and
understand totally and I think there are
smart ways they could have addressed it
like they they've had episodes about a
poo before like there's I mean the
octuples episode but also just like
exploring his marriage and stuff yeah
they have up who episode it's not like
they can't delve into that character
right and I mean obviously some citizen
season 29 it hasn't been great for a
years now especially if you like or used
to like seasons two through your like
nine that sweet spot but they they
didn't have to literally have Lisa look
at the camera and be like this was fine
20 years ago when Hank Azaria one day
Emmy for doing the voice so yeah there's
that anyway Futurama is a great
television show though you know it's a
great tip you know what you know what a
great shows what anime anime is great
Simpsons is one of your favorite animes
growing up yes totally my favorite anime
yeah well we do have some some happy
news Patra news about things that were
handled well and this comes from kotaku
also the western version of a link
between worlds has more about body
positivity so this is I really love
translation and localization and so
collide mandolin who you probably know
him from his fan translation of mother3
and the website legends of localization
he took a look at a link between worlds
and basically picked out a part with the
Zora queen that was localized totally
differently into English than it was in
the original Japanese and it's really
cool so do you want to take this next
bit give us the background what's up
with Azure Queen sure okay so in the
story Zora Zora Queen grows to a large
size after a thief steals a gem the help
control and focus for power now the game
requires link to find the gem and
restore the Queen to her original form
so and so in the original Japanese
there's characters that refer to her
larger sized negatively so and they all
like because there's aura they have
looks like sentence in dirt justice aura
but it doesn't translate anything that's
just having in their sentences but they
say but I actually kind of like her even
looking like that Zora
what a relief Sora the Queen has
regained her beauty's aura and in the
localization in the western version
those lines were removed and the line is
but I actually kind of liked her even
looking like that Zora became we've got
to get it back in her pool before all is
lost and so it was more about protecting
the character rather than protecting her
beauty as the Queen and this is just
like like I don't think I don't know I
don't have a huge like big opinion about
it but I just think it's a really cool
detail on how localization can really
transform a character and how important
localization is and maybe you do if
you're interested in like what the
original japanese is these kinds of
resources can give you some insight into
those characters and then the
localization is like oh well for Western
audiences maybe we don't need to have
those kinds of like little jokey humor
things yeah I think this is just like a
cool thing you know localization is is
an amazing thing because then when games
come over from Japan like if you're not
familiar with what localization exactly
is is that it's not just a translation
of the language because you can get a
very literal translation that won't get
like the emotion across so localization
is kind of okay this is what it directly
translates to now what what what does
this mean in like an American context
you know and how what what are exactly
are they trying to say
what emotions are you trying to portray
that is what localization kind of is and
also like thematically like some things
need to be tweaked automatically for
certain audiences far too either makes
make more sense or to just better fit
like the cultural norms right that are
there like
and like that this isn't even just
including things that don't translate
those of course things that don't
translate from Japanese directly into
English this is just kind of like well
is this something that's even funny in
America yeah or is this something that's
necessary
yeah like humor humor landing is huge
for localization especially as I'm
playing more and more of the Yakuza
series yeah because a lot of the a lot
of like the jokes a lot of the like the
situations and how the characters kind
of like talk about the situations in a
game like Yakuza zero or Yakuza six or
all all those wonderful games it just
like it speaks to its audience like it
has that kind of Western humor and it
has uses western slang to kind of
portray these characters in certain ways
right and it's super effective like yeah
and I think also I talked to eight four
eight four Studios there they're homies
they're good friends of ours I met some
of the people I ate for when I want to
go see you the Nier automata panel at
GDC and they're just very good people
who do a lot of good localization yeah
it's an art form yes so when you do get
those when you do get Japanese games
that are translated very well you know
show some appreciation for localization
mm-hmm um and that's all the time we
have that was six stories like we
promised in 30 minutes or less you know
just a couple quick things before we go
just PSAs Ghost Recon wildlands Splinter
Cell and overwatch retribution events
are both live today so if you're
interested in either of those games they
have new stuff going on we've talked
about Ghost Recon yesterday and we'll be
streaming overwatch right after this I
think yeah we won't be but I I believe
it'll be way Joey's not here is he
it's Joe Joey so Joey probably Joey and
Eric they are gonna our overwatch boys
yes so if you're watching live they'll
be streaming right after this so that's
11:30 a.m. Pt and then if you're not
watching live
we'll have that video up as well if you
are curious about the overwatch and
retribution event yeah and what else Oh
anime is great yeah I'm I'm blazing
through my hero academia yeah
loving it and little witch academia I'm
going to school he's going go to Squam
be a hero and a wit yo anime is a
wonderful thing so just I'll leave you
all with that that's where we'll part
with you thank you so much for watching
thank you Matt Padgett and Tony Wilson
for getting all our stories together
getting those bullet points yes weird
away we love you all
yeah very big help Josh and Eric Tay
Chris Pereira everyone's pitching in to
make this happen
and you are all out there watching and
listening are also helping make this
happen so we hope you stick around every
damn day yeah cuz we'll be back we'll be
back tomorrow let us know what you think
have a good day
goodbye bye